to kenya now where a series of grim
discoveries in a river have local
residents scared and authorities looking
for answers for months dead bodies have
been dumped into the river yala it's
unclear who the people are how they died
and who was disposing of them dwe's
felix moringa has more on the mystery
the revila pours into africa's largest
lake lake victoria for months now local
residents have been making a gruesome
find dead bodies in various states of
decomposition that have been dumped in
the river
i have no idea where these bodies are
coming from they are bound some have
their heads tied with nylon other bodies
have their hands tied
people say some of the bodies they have
found show signs of mutilation or
torture but the local doctor says he has
found nothing suspicious
the type of injury that
is manifested is basically drowning
we are not able to ascertain whether
there is any other type of injury in
these bodies unless and until a
postmortem is conducted
police and activist groups are giving
different accounts of the number of dead
rights group amnesty international has
voiced its concern and accuses
authorities of downplaying the matter we
are here because we know that a minimum
of 30 bodies a minimum of 30 bodies have
been found in the last six months so do
not let anybody teach us or cheat us
that there were 30 bodies over the last
two years that is not the truth
this is not the truth
even more bodies have been retrieved
from the river this week people hoping
to find missing relatives among the dead
have traveled from as far away as
mombasa on the coast
no one knows where these bodies are
coming from because this river is quite
lengthy it's about 200 kilometers long
so
the bodies could be coming from even the
neighboring counties
local police have been unable to provide
answers leaving residents in the area
terrified
once i mean i'll go forward
i'm afraid because i often watch
football at the local bars at night but
now that we are finding these bodies i'm
afraid of meeting these people who are
dumping bodies in the river if they see
you they might kill you and dump him so
that makes me afraid of being out at
night
an investigative team from the capital
nairobi has arrived to find out why
these bodies are being dumped in the
river and who is responsible
until then the rival will continue to
hold the secret to this grim mystery